der gleiche typ der da jetzt wieder
vorne dran denkt alter schwede
acom kopfhörer auf hallo mein name ist
super und ich habe höhenangst
curdin perl 1 höhenangst hat sollte man
sich eigentlich keine scary compilations
wegen höhen und keine ahnung was
angucken aber genau das ist das was wir
heute machen picard insane 2006 team
scared enough to be your pants ich war
extra grad schon pizzen damit das nicht
passiert ich habe vor einiger zeit schon
mal auf so ein video reagiert
nein nein
da hatte ich auch eine menge angst und
das hier ist jetzt das gleiche video was
für schauen werden nur halt ab der
stelle wo ich letztes mal pausiert habe
hier klicken einfach mal auf play und
sehen dann schon hier ist wieder die
tante die da letztes mal so ich kann mir
so was nicht anschauen
ich denke dann immer so dass ich in
dieser situation bin deswegen könnte ich
auch nie beispielsweise via game spielen
wo man klettern muss man nach unten
kommt man doch genau du könnten jeder
mensch potsdam 8 heilige scheiße
nein nein nein als wenn da keine
okay ganz ruhig bleiben luca ganz ruhig
bleiben
ich bitte euch da ist war eine sicherung
hier mit diesem was ist das hier sondern
bums hier und hier vorn haben wir auch
so was aber eher das ist auch nicht
schön die weit dass hier untergeht meine
damen und herrn warum macht man sowas
denn ich finde sowas sieht noch
einigermaßen vernünftig aus also sowas
darf da okay
jedoch kann einer noch schlechter
englisch als ich habe es auch noch
schöner dslr fotos machen wieder steht
ja hammergeil okay da stehst du auch
aber da hat man zumindest noch so eine
kleine sicherung so er kann
ich verstehe nicht was es den leuten
bringt ja ihr bekommt respekt dafür dass
ihren lebens müde seid kulig bekommen
respekt dafür weil ich beschissene
videos machen
und wo ich bekomme ich auch keinen
respekt für ja wir wissen hier ist einer
der irgendwie der von gott als erich da
das lager überhaupt nicht hoch aus wie
im schnee aber hier ist einfach ein
fucking drücke dem das sind locker 100
meter hängt da dran alter und eisig kalt
aus er hängt mit einer hand alter zeit
jeden bescheid er muss noch einmal kurz
abrutschen das ist ob ich der gleiche
typ der jetzt wieder vorne dran denken
alter schwede
acom komm hör doch auf erhält einfach
100 meter ließ die creative suite rp
was geht ab man überlegt man da kommt
ein winzer oder man denkt sich nur ganz
kurze was wird passieren wenn ich jetzt
vor der überfall ist doch nur krank
bitte leute nehmt euch an solchen
vollidioten kein beispiel macht es nie
zu hause nahm auch nicht aufs raus
klettern ich meine auch sowas alter das
ist doch nicht mehr schön was die da
machen die balancieren einfach drüber
meine fresse
[Musik]
man muss sagen hier links ist wenigstens
wasser wenn darunter fällt hat eine
chance zu überleben aber er hat ja
vorher schon gezeigt wie wacklig das
ganze ist und das einzige was ich in
solchen videos die natur ist die leute
an meckern und denen sagen das sieht
doch dumpf nimmt in der tag erklärten
turmhoch das karten können aber auch
ganz normale mitarbeiter da einfach ok
glaube ich doch nicht immer diese
riesige stadt was ist das shanghai oder
oder tokio oder was das ich glaube sogar
dass shanghai aber ein alter schuh tor
hey
das ich kann mir das nicht geben
viele hände ich weiß nicht aber meine
hände sind gerade schwitzen ass
schwitz nass ich weiß nicht ob nur ich
diese probleme haben mit so enorme höhen
angst aber ich komm mal wenn man sich
doch so etwas angucken
das ist doch nicht mehr vor allem da im
schnee alter du musst nur einmal eine
rutschige stelle erwischen also ich
würde ich am liebsten mal sowas angucken
wo so was schiefgeht damit die zuschauer
hier ist allgemein gesehen
das sollte man echt nicht nachmachen
aber ich glaube dass ich dann auch noch
barfuß ist er nicht schon kalt genug da
draußen mit dem schnee dann noch eine
badehose ankommt kollege die planer
richtig angenehme temperaturen hier auch
okay das ist wieder da
was das immer diese verpackte
autobahnbrücke was denken sich die leute
okay dass eine autobahnbrücke da fährt
man normalerweise mit dem auto drüber
ich kenne aber hoch wie kommt sofort
fest immer dieser typ dem man es auch
immer barfuß alter ich verstehe das
nicht es ist immer der gleiche irgendwie
wahrscheinlich gibt es nur einen
menschen auf diesem planeten der so
dummes und das ist er
er filmt sich auf dem riesigen stern da
oben da oben ganz oben ist das hochhaus
er läuft da wieder barfuß aber okay ich
meine wenn darunter fällt wenigstens
noch motorradhelm auf vor allem bei
diesem video gerade erst bei der hälfte
das heißt ich werde das video jetzt
gleich wieder stoppen weil ich hier
wieder nur am schwitzen wir am stottern
ich weiß nicht ob ihr die neue
kooperation von wachstum ihr mitbekommen
habt das hier ist jetzt keinen placement
oder gesponsert oder so allerdings
sollte ich dort von einem 100 bis 200
meter haus an der wand runter laufen
also nicht von wegen springen und es ist
eine sekunde vorbei sondern ich sollte
wirklich eine wand runter laufen
es geht nicht es gebe ja und daran habt
ihr jetzt gerade erkannt was für eine
enorme höhenangst ich habe oder
zumindest respekt vor der höhe weil ich
trau mich auch mit dem flugzeug zu
fliegen und irgendwie auch hochhäuser zu
gehen aber solange es so bald es darauf
ankommt das ist das eine chance besteht
dass man dabei wirklich verrecken könnte
bin ich raus und dann sehe ich hier
solche forderung von miguel muss doch
die nächste szene freunde hier da haben
wir wieder ihnen hier natürlich ist
wieder der einzige am start okay das ist
jetzt drei meter höhe oder so
h
ok an der stelle würde ich sagen reicht
mir das jetzt auch wenn euch das video
hier gefallen hat würde ich mich
definitiv über ein like freuen
schaffen wir gallardo 60.000 ich weiß
nicht irgendwie schafft in letzter zeit
alles das video hier geht noch acht
minuten
das heißt wenn ich das noch weiter
darauf reagieren sondern noch einen
dritten part aus der reihe machen soll
dann lasst auch mal leiter und schreibt
heute in die kommentare ihr findet jetzt
ins meile eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf
abonniert dem einen kanal das ist
kostenlos und verpasst keine videos mehr
da oben findet auch meinen shop
eingeblendet und hier unten ist ein
anderes video also ich hab gerade ich
habe die ganzen herzrasen